foreign
[Music]
for Monday November 28th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
Ben McKenzie is an actor best known for
his roles in the TV shows the OC and
Gotham but lately he's added another
title to his resume
outspoken crypto skeptic at the Wall
Street journals Tech live event last
month Mackenzie who has a degree in
economics discussed his feelings about
digital currencies and the book he's
writing about it with wsj reporter Eric
schwartzel when they spoke the crypto
exchange FTX hadn't yet been hit by its
liquidity crisis or filed for bankruptcy
but other crypto firms had collapsed and
many digital currencies values had
fallen significantly from their highs
here are highlights from their
conversation Ben McKenzie thanks for
joining us at Tech live my pleasure
you're here today to talk about
cryptocurrency how did that happen
I just became fascinated by sort of
you know money
we made it up
it doesn't exist right it's a social
construct just like government religion
it relies on a critical mass for it to
have value and so all these people were
ascribing value to this thing which to
me I was deeply suspicious of and it's
led me down an investigative rabbit hole
but there's a difference between being
suspicious of crypto and speaking out
and leveraging celebrity to to raise
awareness why did you decide to to make
that that leap I mean I think it
probably would start in the fall of 2021
when you published a piece in slate I
mean you didn't really hold back you you
called it um celebrity crypto Shilling
as a moral disaster
uh and and it was inspired by a number
of uh other celebrities who were taking
the opposite approach and and signing
endorsement deals to promote uh
cryptocurrencies why decide to not just
sort of tell your friend that he was an
idiot for investing in Bitcoin but
instead become you know the the TV star
who's speaking out against crypto
well
Robert Schiller the uh Nobel Prize
winner Economist has talked about how
economic narratives spread
they spread first of all their reaction
to real things
so in the case of cryptocurrency I would
say the Genesis is the subprime crisis
this peer-to-peer currency that would
avoid all into intermediaries and would
democratize decentralize uh the
financial structure which and so failed
so many Americans so it's so it had it
it seems to come from real need and I
was fascinated by that at the same time
what the more I studied it the more I
actually looked
at the bones of it
it wasn't doing the things that it said
it was doing it was highly centralized
crypto had basically seemingly to me
anyway created an entire parallel
Financial structure
a financial structure parallel to the
regulated one that was completely
unregulated or more or less unregulated
so the propensity for fraud was enormous
and I worried that
these economic this economic narrative
would would spread as it had already had
done like wildfire I felt like things
were going to go poorly well like a lot
of people are going to lose some money
and the book you're working on now is
called easy money right what is
why easy to find to find Easy in that
context for me so it has multiple
meanings it's about the creation of this
money that isn't money it's also about
how all of this started which I would
say is the subprime crisis and our
failure to address
you know some deeper systemic issues
with our
deeply flawed Financial system which has
created massive levels of mistrust
deservedly so perhaps
and so people are well they're investing
in crypto for all sorts of reasons if
you look at the polling they're
investing in it because it's a new way
of investing and it's easy that's those
are the first two answers it's not
because they understand blockchain
technology or believe in it or or even
use it as a currency because of course
most people it's almost nobody is
there's not like a philosophical
underpinning driving most of these
decisions for the majority right well
let me ask you something so if you were
if you were building a character based
on what you're seeing is driving a lot
of these folks into crypto what would
that character's motivations be what do
you think it sounds like you're
describing almost like a need being
fulfilled oh for sure yeah and I'm
trying to get it maybe this what you
would see is this psychological or even
sociological reasons for that well they
vary widely I mean incredibly widely so
it's difficult and I don't want to
stereotype but if you look at the
polling you know 42 percent of men 18 to
29 have purchased use bought
cryptocurrency at some point in their
lives that's a large number that's
almost half that's a big number so it is
younger it is male but you have people
of all walks of life and it is
interesting I mean it it it's
you know it's not particularly they're
not a lot of distinctions between
um socioeconomic classes in terms of
participation
um and people with a lot of money people
with middle money people with with not a
lot of money have all used it um there
are differences in gender it's about two
and a half to one
um male to female
um and there are differences in race
um minority groups are more likely to to
invest in cryptocurrencies so how old
were you when the OC premiered
pretty quickly yes looking at looking at
a future with potential earnings you
know that you would not imagine before
do you do you think back on that time do
you do you see commonalities when you're
talking to folks who you're describing
this sort of pursuing this easy money
yeah that's a great question young men
sociologically they make Port they are
very risk on they make a lot of
decisions that perhaps they shouldn't
and on the flip side on the flip side
they also take risks that sometimes pay
off wildly I'm just skeptical as I look
at the and as I get into the weeds as I
get into the gears so to speak that that
they're really improving things what I
see
is that most people lose money
and for for very obvious reasons the
technology doesn't work particularly
well
the markets are more or less unregulated
there's massive information asymmetries
you know you're effectively sitting down
at a poker table across from sorry maybe
it's dates dates me but across from Phil
he'll move one of the greatest poker
players ever lived you know and you know
you're not even aware of it and this guy
is you know he's gonna run a new ragged
could you win a hand sure you could win
a hand but over the long run you sit
there long enough
you're going to lose do you think that
the the crypto winter whatever you want
to call it the volatility we're in right
now do you see this as uh confirming
what you had identified as as issues
with the system or do you think this is
just volatility that's representative of
of the um of the currency like what what
do you think is you mean the fact that
two trillion dollars more or less
disappeared overnight do I feel like
that's a validation
yes yes I do think that it's a
validation yeah I mean maybe that's
self-serving but yeah good timing yeah I
think so so could crypto come back I
guess as someone yeah right um sure I
mean anything could happen right it
could start snowing tomorrow in Laguna
um uh
the thesis of the book
or one of the primary Theses of the book
is that the easy money that we have
injected into the system has created all
sorts of
I mean
it's it's a massive speculative bubble
right and the things that pop the first
are the things that are the most
speculative of course it is what else is
it what does it do right I went to the
only country in the world that's trying
to use it as currency El Salvador
no one's using it
because it doesn't work
because it's not a currency I don't
think it's coming back anytime soon
unless it provides some sort of use case
unless we have something that it does
better than other things that have also
that also have flaws you know what has
it improved
um I just don't I don't see it happening
in the near term could blockchain have
uses in other sure I don't know I don't
have anything against blockchain it's a
distributed Ledger I'm not mad at a
distributed Ledger I'm mad at a massive
amount of what I think is you know a
massive speculative bubble and and what
I think is fraud most likely underneath
it
um so could could
you know blockchain public key
encryption this kind of stuff uh have
value in the future monetarily sure yeah
of course no problem with that but but
when how
I don't think that's anytime soon well
Ben we will look forward to the book
Thank you for being here today yeah my
pleasure thanks everyone
all right that's it for today's Tech
news briefing if you want more Tech
stories check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]